it was a completely vile weekend of
disinformation and propaganda from the
president and he also had another one of
these helicopter press press conferences
where he's yelling at the cameras while
the helicopter whirs in the background
and this time he said in his defense of
his handling of kovat 19 he says listen
a lot more people have died from the flu
at the time he said no one had died yet
that changed just hours after this press
conference we'll get to that momentarily
but most bizarrely Donald Trump claimed
as the helicopter word in the background
that the government is ordering elements
of medical now you might be saying well
the elements of medical what David it
sounds like there's a word missing there
no just elements of medical take a look
this tremendous spirit a lot of spirit
and as you know with the flu on average
will is from 26,000 to 78,000 people a
year even more than that in some some
cases some years we haven't lost anybody
yet and hopefully we can keep that
intact we there have been no deaths in
the United States at all a lot of that's
attributable to the fact that we close
the border very early otherwise it could
be a different story so we'll we'll just
keep doing a good job we're ordering a
lot of supplies we're ordering a lot of
a lot of elements and frankly we
wouldn't be ordering unless it was
something like this but we're ordering a
lot of different elements of medical we
are working on cures and we're getting
some very good results does he mean
elements like they're ordering elements
from the periodic table like cesium and
barium that he thinks of medical uses
this is how you know as if we didn't
before that Trump has no idea what's
going on we're ordering elements of
medical he might as well say we're
ordering widgets and ding-dongs it's
it's it's communicating as much value
and meaning what he is saying is how
much how much we would get if he said
we're ordering ding-dongs elements of
medic
has about the same amount of meeting and
this guy is in so far over his head that
it almost exceeds the English languages
ability to describe it it's blathering
it's lies it's nonsense there's almost
Trump is almost existing in the event
imagine a Venn diagram where you have
Ronald Reagan's cognitive decline which
is not a joke it's nothing to laugh at
it's it's horrible George Bush's and
competence with the added element of
Donald Trump's extreme weaponized
narcissism the Venn diagram of those
three is where Donald Trump is operating
and lastly by the way if kovat 19 is
overblown trumped up by Dems all under
control
why would Trump even be ordering
so-called elements of medical that they
wouldn't normally order it doesn't
really make sense for something that's
perfectly under control to take action
that is out of the ordinary it probably
doesn't matter it's all merely
uninformed propaganda and then to close
up this insane copter press conference
before going to the next one Trump also
again was asked about the stock market
implosion and he keeps blaming it on
Democrats instead of the growing global
pandemic
which Trump is not particularly
inspiring conference on confidence on
well I think it's just people don't know
let's see unknown you know they look at
it and they say how long will this last
I think they're not very happy with the
Democrat candidates when they see them I
think that has an impact yeah world
markets are crashing as the outbreak
spreads because people are just really
upset with the Democratic candidates I
have an unbeatable deal for my viewers
for just 20 bucks you can get an entire
year of award-winning antivirus plus a
VPN which makes you anonymous online you
can use them both on three of your
devices when you use the link down below
all made possible by our good friends
over at total AV they're one of our
sponsors one of the most trusted names
in computer security I use total AV
antivirus to protect my desktop computer
my phone and my laptop if you're using
the internet on any device that doesn't
have an added layer of defense you're
opening yourself up to all kinds of
online threats total AV antivirus helps
keep you safe from viruses spyware
ransomware adware works on Windows Mac
iOS and Android it'll protect your
computer smartphone even your tablet all
of which are susceptible to online
attacks that can otherwise be a complete
nightmare to deal with take it from me
safeguarding yourself online from this
stuff is a lot more simple than you
might realize
you just need an anti-virus system like
total AV that's known for its
reliability you install it once it runs
in the background you don't even have to
think about it and the best part it's
completely affordable right now because
they're offering 80% off to our audience
for just 20 bucks you get total a V's
premium antivirus on three of your
devices for a whole year and as part of
that deal you'll get totally these very
dependable VPN which makes you anonymous
when you're browsing the Internet the
VPN alone is worth the twenty bucks
check out total AV click the link right
underneath this video